وفي الاسابيع الاخيره تركز التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه تركز في
مدينه جنين ومخيمها حيث نفذ الاحتلال
سلسله عمليات عسكريه لاعتقالي واغتيال
مقومين فلسطينيين التصعيد الاسرائيلي
وتركز كذلك في نابلس وتحديدا جنوب المدينه
حيث بلده حوار وبورين كذلك طالت العمليات
العسكريه للاحتلال المخيم عقبه جبر جنوب
غربي اريحا
ومنذ مطلع العام الجاري قتل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ثمانين الفلسطينيا خلال
الاقتحامات لمدن الضفه الغربيه وفي
المقابل قتل 14 اسرائيليا واصيب 25 بينهم
جندي من جيش الاحتلال خلال عمليات نفذها
مقاومون فلسطينيون وتجاوز عدد العمليات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه خمسا وثلاثين عمليه
ابرز هذه العمليات عمليه اطلاق نار في حي
نيفي يعقوب الاستيطاني بالقدس المحتله
نفذها الشهيد خيري علقم في يناير الماضي
واسهرت عن مقتل سبعه اسرائيليين كذلك
عمليه اطلاق نار في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس
اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين اثنين ونفذ الشهيد
عبد الفتاح خروشه وفي السابع والعشرين من
يناير الماضي اطلقوا مقاومون فلسطينيون
النار على سياره اسرائيليه في منطقه
الاغوار في
مما اسفر عن مقتل اسرائيلي